I have always loved the far North and I have often let my mind wander around up there.
I have flown above the inland ice for hours and looked down upon the ice landscape, which I thought to be permanent.
We’re talking about permafrost because the Arctic perhaps is a place on Earth
where it is a common perception that time stands still.
And where one can also locate the past – you can drill trough the ice, find ice cores,
and find examples of how life was a long time ago.
I have of course read about sliding glaciers.
I have seen the photos that show how a glacier has moved during the last 200 years.
Civilizations have always emerged by the waterfronts, for instance in the Middle East by the rivers.
What is unbelievable today is that everything is moving so fast,
that we now stand before great changes regarding the Arctic.
The Arctic challenges our reasoning power, our fantasy, in a number of ways.
The present threat, by all accounts, is the great tide, a flood, which once again makes water crucial to all of us.
It is not perceived as a catastrophe; We are not sailing towards an iceberg like Titanic.
No, the entire Earth has become the Titanic,
which is threatened not by water as solid liquid – ice – but rather in the liquid state which is so imperceptible.
It comes so imperceptibly that at some point the Arctic will come to us as well.
Actually, the Arctic is already here.
When the highways begin to crackle, when the ground water rises it is because the Arctic has arrived to the wealthier areas.
It is not part of our daily consciousness, also because we don’t live in what we perceive as threatened areas.
We talk about climate refugees, and by that we mean people who escape dessert areas.
But there will be a time where the Dutch, the Danes, and the Britons will have to escape from the rising oceans.
This is what the Arctic has become to me; a metaphor for dramatic change,
whereas it used to be an image of something entirely static.
I have read about polar expeditions, I have read many books about it,
and I have always hoped that the Arctic could stay a sacred space for me; a place for fairy tales.
Today, I can only think of it as a future nightmare.
Nevertheless, I cannot be sure. Nobody can.
The worst thing is that even in our time climate change deniers, now also in The White House,
still have so much power.